when they talk about Sweden and mention
what they think about they think of
Abbas music they think of Volvo's cars
and they think of IKEA furniture hi I'm
Michael Moynihan with recent TV and
today we're talking to you Swedish
author Johan Norberg author of in
defense of global capitalism and a
senior fellow at the Cato Institute
Johan we want to talk about Sweden today
and let's let's just begin with the
misperceptions about sweet polly Toynbee
from the left-wing newspaper in england
the Guardian said Sweden is the most
successful Society that the world has
ever known
you I suspect disagree with that can you
tell us why that's wrong the problem is
that this is an an ancient leftist myth
about this utopian paradise of Sweden
where all the social problems have been
solved and it's possible to have high
growth even though we have high taxes to
understand the Swedish model of Taxation
is on you also have to understand that
it's really not a way of taking from the
rich and giving to the poor which is the
perspective of the hope of many American
and European intellectuals when they
look at the tax levels in Sweden because
if you try to tax people with high
incomes big businesses capital gains
businesses and so on then you destroy
the economy and the Social Democrats
they understand that so what they do
instead is that they have their fairly
okay tax levels when it when if you're
really wealthy if you're really rich
what do we do instead is that we tax
consumption we have a 25% v8e
consumption tax in Sweden which means
that the poor pays they pay the highest
proportion of that what they always
failed to realize is that we created
wealth when Sweden was a free trade free
market Society what has happened since
is that Sweden has become a mixed
economy where with some free markets and
some government intrusion you can easily
see that
the free market parts they're successful
but at the same time we could see things
like Sweden being one of the healthiest
populations on the planet had the
highest sick-leave statistics in Europe
because it paid off not to be there and
for lack of social control and no
specific controls of that well if you
can get 80% of your wage when you stay
at home then you probably do that and
voters rejected that because after a
while I mean there's a tipping point
somewhere after a while you begin to see
that look everybody else is sort of
using these benefits and not
contributing to society if that
continues I'm a loser if I work so this
has to stop somewhere and that's why the
Social Democrats were were thrown out of
office let's talk about market reforms
in Sweden explain for us you know some
of these sort of more market liberal or
libertarian advances that Sweden has
made over the past 15 years or 20 years
well yet to be fair Sweden is one of the
European countries that have liberalized
the most I would say in the last 20 or
so years and especially if you compare
it to the European continent one of the
reasons was that we had a very
problematic destructive economic crisis
in the early 1990s because the old
policies really failed and education
didn't pay off businesses weren't doing
quite well so we're the center-right
government they began to really
liberalize product markets at that time
the Social Democrats said that
deregulating telecom which almost no
country at Dyea done before was a weird
libertarian neoliberal experiment that
would destroy the telephone business in
Sweden and of course it paved the way
for Ericsson tell it to the Swedish
success when it comes to cell phones and
so on when we looked in at the turn of
the century at the 50 largest Swedish
companies not one had been created after
1970 I mean these are the old companies
that were produced in during Sweden's
lays a fair period was weaned was the
most most open to businesses and then
they've been kept in place let's talk a
bit about health care what would you
tell an American who
knew very little about the Swedish
healthcare system well first of all I
would have really look at the broader
picture where does the health care
technologies come from that's the
Swedish hospitals use where the drugs
and the medicines come from well all of
it is really invented implemented in the
American competitive health care system
so in effect what we're doing is that
we're we're free riding on the
entrepreneurship that goes on on the in
the competition that goes on in the
American healthcare system so whatever
you do and whatever the consequences for
Americans I'm not the one to to really
have a strong opinion on that please
please please don't introduce any sort
of single-payer or government mandated
health care system here because in that
case it would be disastrous for all the
rest of us who parrot a parasite upon
upon we mentioned that goes on here do
you have to somehow ration health care
the demand is unlimited the resources
are limited so either you have to ration
it with prices and making sure that
people pay for it themselves and think
about what they want to have covered or
your ration it with waiting lines I mean
if you have a condition in Sweden it
could be serious conditions we have
stories about that in the media all the
time people have brain tumor and get the
response that yeah just wait in line
until we have the machinery and the
doctors ready for you thanks for joining
us you know hon for reason TV I'm
Michael Moynihan
[Music]